welcome to this video round two coverage
of the dashi memorial tournament held in
azerbaijan at the moment in chunkier yes
round one was pretty exciting with some
wins and some close wins or games close
to a wind this is what I wanted wanted
to say round two wasn't that exciting I
can tell you that right away being
honest with you so I'm doing a recap
video there will be some interesting
moment some near the end of it but I'm
going through of the games quickly yeah
first game to check is um Micky Adams
with white playing fabiano caruana
currently world number two the elms lost
the first round game against kramnik and
kawana escaped slightly tricky situation
against mumba dro so let's get going was
it against mamedyarov no it wasn't was
wine in that game hmm forgot to was wine
in that game but well corona had to hit
some some tricky moments to to survive
it was another yar of right this was
Mammadyarov karana yeah okay let's see
this game we have one if for by micky
adams as he usually plays and we have
the Berlin yeah not exactly the kind of
opening that yeah makes you jump from
your seats and run around enjoy it some
not so exciting in some cases and this
game unfortunately is no great exception
after d three atoms of what's the
endgame karana went Bishop c5 and now
Adams went for the trade and played 93
yeah the trailer on c6 has been played
quite a bit also by world champion
magnus carlsen but he usually continued
then with night BTW two or sometimes a
3h three
or combination of those moves the night
on the two seems more flexible than the
knight on c3 because here we sometimes
have this move one night be three or we
can still go to g3 while on c3 and a
little bit puzzled they have to admit on
c3 it well it doesn't do much there so
it has to be regrouped and well this is
a regrouping but if you want to go to g3
why not do it via d1f d2f one mmm I'm
not totally certain there um black is
reacting with castles yeah white cannot
take that out immediately I mean
theoretically speaking he can but it
leads nowhere to turn 24 should be 325
deform black is having a good position
yeah so why shouldn't take you just
played age 397 yeah this movements maybe
not so obvious but it is fairly typical
for the black set up what like wants to
do keeping the bishop pair and now we
see this c5a blocking move in the center
preventing deform and black goes for
this regrouping yeah he regrouped his
night from f6 to c6 very standard time
of play sometimes black also goes for 97
f 86 d for now there are ya versions of
this maneuver but essentially it's
always the idea to improve the night get
it to the great square on d4 and this is
what happened night to deform yeah white
essentially in this position only has 11
porn break left that's F for ya and we
see that after a couple of moves
everything that looks very very obvious
white went there for obvious let's say
very standard am A five trying to use
the rope here and f1 is as mentioned the
only pawn leaver that white has so after
the trade and and a kind of more trades
get to this simplified position where
black is now activating a screen coming
to deform yeah it's a situation where it
is very difficult for both sides to do
anything at all yeah Queen III Queen
trade chat in this check here by Kara
wanna look f1 is very logical Luke a to
Luke f2 yeah you cannot get the drift an
aunt yet they agreed to a draw oh it was
a repetition I'm not sure if someone
said it three times or if they just
agreed on on drawing yeah that's not the
most exciting change game ever but um
well it sometimes happens if both
players want to be very solid I think
Adams on wanted them quiet game after
his loss in round one and Kara wanna
with black here I mean Adams is not the
kind of person to play something fishy
against trying to win some kind of crazy
game Quran also went for a solid
approach and well sometimes it's just
just to to sound and say in a situation
or in a line like that or you trade on
play Knight c3 there is relatively
little to play for and sometimes it just
never gets off the ground the skin this
is this kind of game ok the next game
going to look at is crumb dick against
westleigh so so we have a duel of two
winners right in round one and the
chrome [ __ ] repeating is opening
actually you went again night at 3g
three which is always funny for me to
see because this is what I do play in
tournament chess quite often so on
kramnik it's often get interesting to
watch for me see what what ideas he has
so is playing d5 and g6 a line that was
very much a backwater
10 20 years ago nobody knew of this is
kind of move order but vishy anand
played this against cars in 2013 in
there um it was Game one or Game two of
the World Championship match i think in
one and since then people have
recognized that this is a pretty decent
move water especially if you have the
gruene felt in your repertoire the thing
is that like playing this quickly this
fianchetto black basically threatens to
push e5 if white is not reacting and
raise castles let's say black gets in
five and now he has a nice porn center
which is pretty much like a reversed
pills defense perk defends them adam is
very very comparable yeah like a
fianchetto variation against the pills
wear white is very comfortable yeah i
mean not very comfortable not what not a
huge edge but it's a very sound setup
and the tempo down doesn't really change
matters like equalizers here very very
easily so why it is almost forced to do
something in the center now se5 is a
threat in some sense default Kramnik
plate and this is what almost all of the
top players do you can also play see
form like cards and tried it in this run
championship match game here black has
some options you can play an aggressive
deform you can play e6 this is what I
sometimes play there I mean mostly in
blitz chess it's it's a bit dodgy this
line a little bit and like can take this
is the most solid way to play as island
plate and the World Championship match
something like that and black has a very
very decent position I'm sure about e5
though I think they play five um yeah
black has no particular problems chronic
therefore when deform and west day so no
Knight f6 for complete symmetry castles
castles now the most ambitious move as
the move c4 and by father main
theoretical continuation however this
leads to the main line blumenfeld
fianchetto web Black now has the basic
choice between taking
and playing c6 now after takes wide
place 9 a-3 and then like and play 90 60
can play c3 the start of some long lines
when general black is considered to be
quite ok there's also c 6 which is also
considered to be quite ok yeah kramnik
try something different she played night
bd2 it's a somewhat slow looking move
but it has some idea wants to go see for
without allowing this particular capture
d takes see form um however um Wesley so
now as black played differently you did
not play let's say c6 which would be
possible and after c-4 would be a simple
transposition into c4 c6 night bd2 he
played something um um yeah that gives
the the positioner its independent
flavor let's say he went tonight to e4
just centralizing this night right away
it looks a bit um uncommon or it looks a
bit out of the ordinary to move the
night again or the Sun losing a bit of
time but this night moves definitely
does one thing it opens up the whole my
mouse is acting up Wow universe it's
opening up the long diagonal and
prepares for play against the d4 pawn
with see 5 or sometimes maybe 9075 so
opening up the diagonal is not a not a
bad idea door and it just loses a bit of
time if white now is not playing what
chrome leg place Kramnik took on your
form um you don't have much choice
actually let's say you go see for just
two to show the the possibilities after
c4 black has a again a choice he can
play c6 transposing into the c4 c6
business this is in fact a line that is
perfectly possible or he can decide to
take and just naturally spawn when now
we see that this open bishop is doing
something pressurizing d4 for example
let's say rook see 196 be all of a
sudden
that there is some pressure on the pond
94 is an interesting idea chronic plate
um in a way yeah I'm not saying he tried
to refute it because you pretty quickly
see that it is no refutation but he
tried to give it an independent taste
this continuation he took plate 95 here
however we see as mentioned the open
diagonal like just took the pawn and
chrome Nick traded and played rugby 196
and Bishop before so this is something
that was played relatively quickly he
also bike ramnik so it seems that he had
some head maybe look at it this kind of
idea before whether it's not quite clear
what he what is some yeah if he thought
that this is giving white something or
if he M yeah how how it came to this
kind of position hawaii was allowing it
on yeah it's simply equal it's what i'm
trying to say there's nothing much going
on white has a slight very slight
symbolic let's say pull because of
superior activity but we see that the
pawn structure is entirely symmetrical
okay there's a poll on c7 and white as
opponents III but this is really nothing
to write home about and we see that like
it's regrouping this night to see to d6
covering also be seven and then step by
step managed to get his pieces
coordinated the symmetrical nature of
the position makes it very difficult to
get anywhere bishop to just to be 795
yeah the only thing that like absolutely
has to do is to avoid playing something
really really stupid for example like
taking only five that's something that
doesn't really help a lot yeah you give
right an excellent bishop let's say here
King f2 the int a situation like this
can be tricky for black yeah you have
less space so
that activates the king those kind of
things black should probably avoid it's
not like he's losing not saying that but
this definitely gives white some some
hope for an advantage like has to be
very very young um yeah modest they're
just trying to trade down slowly and
this is what so basically did you know
just some slow solid moves white try to
open up the Queen side but here 95 was
an important counter-attacking move
getting this counter play going well
wide was attacking on c5 yeah we had
even more trades yeah here I first
thought when I saw this vision okay
maybe white can try to get something
against this this somewhat isolated pawn
it's not completely connected to the
rest of legs pawn structure but there is
really nothing nothing serious going on
like quickly get since King involved and
yeah there's really nothing going on at
the end we had even this traded and
ultimately rooks traded after which they
agree to a draw so this opening idea was
night bd2 and then 94 leads to rather
boring position to to just be very frank
about it there was simply not much going
on I think Wesley so um yeah it looks
like he played in a precise way here in
this position as i mentioned i think
white is a little bit better so maybe
this is what chrome nick was was playing
for you just said okay I know I'm never
ever going to lose this game and maybe a
like two out of ten there will be some
kind of inaccurate continuation that
that I might be able to use so very very
safe from kind of play here form for
white from chrome legs point of view but
not very exciting to watch
from outside have to say okay let's go
for the next game this is honest Giri
with white against Ralph Mammadov let's
get going we have a sloth defense which
is a slight surprise as Mammadov is
usually known for his Kings Indian he's
playing the Kings Indian regularly and
in general is a rather sharp and
uncompromising player it shows in his
opening repertoire the slav is it seems
a new addition to his repertoire he has
played it before just a few weeks ago
but it's nothing that he does regularly
so certainly something they'd give me
head in his preparation but maybe not
with us with the super highest priority
you never know ok went with queen bee
three in line that I also play regularly
and take stakes and Bishop g4 was played
yeah this line is one of two main
responses to this variation Bishop to g4
Bishop to f5 Bishop g4 is the somewhat
more active continuation and also the
one that I would prefer as black I mean
ok I don't play this opening that much
but if I would have it on the board I
would play Bishop g4 them you know
sometimes just intending to capture the
night maybe get any five night BTW tool
is givers continuation this is some the
most um let's say um sound continuation
or the or the most strategically focused
maybe the right expression there's also
something sharp eye alike Knight c3
night bd7 efore but here it's not clear
if concrete players giving white so much
especially the movie 5 is giving white
some some headache down it's something
that I had recently in blitz games and
two whites never got anywhere
um when I'd be too as mentioned is the
the most strategically in client
continuation why does preparing this
fianchetto this is why not BTW to was
necessary if you go g3 immediately black
would have taken and destroyed white
structure so we cover f3 so that we get
the fianchetto and all this is very
normal looking queen bee three attacking
the b7 porn black is blocking and white
these castles and castles yeah it's
probably a good moment to to talk about
this screen standoff yeah who's who
wants to trade um on when exactly yeah
we can say the following white
absolutely never wants to trade as a
takes be 6 gives black a very decent
game all of a sudden the a file is
opened which is form which is good for
black you can use the a file and he has
ideas to push the beep on up the board
and sometimes annoy the whites pieces on
the queenside why definitely does not
want to trade this is almost universally
the case if you have a pawn structure
like that and what would trade or you
can also look at this I mean think about
this with reversed colors you would
never want to trade them to get this can
of poor information this is not a
weakness at all but rather strength as
black as controlling many squares and
gets in half open file in the actual
game white went night c4 and again we
can ask the question just like want to
take on v3 or not it's funny again a
capture is not a great idea after a
takes beep YTM has the idea to continue
with the night 8 5 News which pressure
rises b7 nc6 black it's not in its in a
super terrible shape here but it's
definitely quite quite annoying too
play yeah let's say you go a 6 9 a-5 and
yeah you have to play somewhat ugly
stuff now like ruka a 7 yeah and because
Ruby 8 that was wrong I'm sorry not this
but let's say how again insert this
point is that Ruby aid as failing due to
Bishop and at fault yeah so you both
sides don't want to trade but black has
Queen a 6 that's a good move looking at
the e to pawn bishop be 2nite b6 and
again why does not want to trade and
plays rooks e1 and black went 90 for
this is technically a new move for
novelty what was known there was some
mostly the capture on c4 which also
leads to yeah to be perfectly honest
something that is very close to equality
roxy 494 intending 96 this x-ray effect
of the Queen on the YouTube porn is felt
quite a bit yeah white has some has
nothing in particular in this position
94 is very very comparable bishop you
want takes takes yeah if white takes
with the rook oops I'm sorry white
cheeks with the rook it doesn't really
need to to that much let's say 96
roubaix for and again Queen B 6 that's
really getting nowhere Black has an
absolutely sound structure with no
weaknesses and no particular problem at
all yeah Queen takes was played and here
the trade and now we have a heaven not
end gaming a queenless middle game as
they say but it's a fairly tame position
where black doesn't have much to fear so
Geary's approach here was a very very
safe one yeah going for a simplified
position maybe you also had in mind that
mammadov is more than yeah
tically focus player is a very concrete
direct player trying to get attacking
games going if possible and well this is
frankly speaking as far away as possible
from any attacking chess it's just a
relatively uneventful position yeah and
they actually just didn't happen when
I'm watching black plate plated well I
think with f6 yeah improving the bishop
position a little bit them went over
here getting some weaknesses in and now
was regrouped to d5 and that's actually
to be honest not much happening in this
this whole game there was a little
sequence that was off a bit of interest
here in 94 after Bishop e7 93 we had a
funny trading sequence where both sides
took a couple of pieces but it is still
eco material black has a good bishop on
d5 and no problem at all yeah you can
even argue if anyone is maybe maybe a
little bit more comfortable it might be
black but it is nothing serious they
continued this game for quite quite a
long while yeah I won't look at it and
in much detail anymore here it's funny
black gave away they upon but there is
no real possibility for white to keep
his material if he goes for night see
for you for example like we'll just
capture and get this pawn back and has
no problems whatsoever before and now in
later with b6 we have a situation where
this night is dominated and only Bishop
g5 was playable which after v takes a
five and hear those trades led to a
completely equal yeah end game with rook
and Bishop against Luke and night yeah
they continued a little bit but there
was really not much happening jack no
side ever got close to to any shiny with
anything yeah in them in the final
position here after would be one
and when they agree to draw there are
many ways to get to a completely equal
position for example if black takes on
f4 he and this line we have a possible
check check them and retreat yeah and
here and why it is always able to attack
those three pawns very often we would
chat to a rook endgame like this let's
see here and then um what are we going
to do now maybe it would be six yeah
this is just just very equal like it's
getting getting nowhere here without his
King yeah and pretty uneventful draw I'm
not sure maybe he wasn't completely
ready for the slot in this in this game
of course they have a rapper to hide
everything but maybe he didn't have a
particularly great idea and wanted to
play such a slow game trying to get
mahmoud off in some some waters that
he's not so comfortable with but he held
his own very um yeah very confidently
there was nothing ever happening here um
next game is mvl maxima sheila graph
with white against vishy anand let's go
there here we go and we have 90 of three
so the very versatile Frenchman going
from 93 he also plays efore d for all
moves and we get a Queens gambit Rogozin
yeah the very popular Rogozin
variegation played by alan before and
something that definitely was on MV else
radar here rate of preparation yeah we
get to this position also something that
has been played quite a bit now I other
wishes coming with a surprise um not a
complete surprise like oh my god this is
a novelty but close to it he plays
Bishop to f5 and I don't know how much
time on
rashi lagrave invested now let's have a
look he played he played two more say
instantly III you played instantly okay
and after night b7 he was was thinking a
bit um okay the thing that I'm getting
at is Bishop f5 is a very rare move I
only had two games in my my database i
think if i remember this correctly but
one of the games is from 2015 and the
black player is mr. jf ski one of the
top players of poland and a second and
help of vision on so if you are having
you not that i have a prepared for on it
but the guys preparing for honor they
also would check what island some yeah
related guys player second strainers
help us whatever and gang f ski was one
of the main guys involved with anons
World Championship preparation so this
move definitely must have been on on
young maxima Sheila graphs radar somehow
III as mentioned was played quickly
after night be seven or ever he took a
long while to come up with the move and
he played Bishop to d3 yeah this does
not look like um a stern test of black
soft legs opening play and what we
essentially get is a Queens gambit
declined card spot structure with the
light squared Bishop traded which never
was regarded as particularly threatening
for black in any in any of any case so
this is a very mmmm yeah harmless moving
in a way um something like queen bee
three is certainly more interesting how
would black some yeah black setup work
in this case quite interesting if black
plays c 5 i'm just making up things here
right i mean i can only assume what was
the preparation there if black plays c5
um you might argue that Bishop we have
six or d take c5
lead to interesting technical play let's
say Queen f6 yeah 9006 this should be
five is a bit awkward hell yeah let's
say Bishop here which is a 727 takes
yeah it's not clear that this is helping
black the deep one will be very very
weak in this kind of situation in most
cases will probably get lost let's go
back yeah probably Queen f6 and now
white may take on d5 an interesting pawn
sacrifice however something that is not
new in these kind of positions quite
often like a sacrificing a pawn for good
development yeah I think maybe the white
player wasn't confident in exploring
some of those lines especially if he
didn't prepare it beforehand 11 idea on
one possibility is also that he had
looked at this line at some point but
forgot what he what he checked after
Queen B 3 by the way black also has to
move Bishop a 5 which is interesting
because the capture is definitely not
that great something sorry Ike has to do
that first I wanted to take on me too in
this kind of situation the be to pawn is
some very tricky to defend yeah what has
to play that we should be 3 to even
continue but even then like has very
very decent play so interesting
complications but as it is so often the
first time it is played um the person
who is surprised to choose or something
less principal Bishop d3 so wish you
just traded and when c6 this is that
typical structure of the cards bottom is
called the Queens gambit declined
exchange yeah this is some something
that happens very frequently and usually
legs main concern in this kind of
structure is the awkward c8 bishop yes
it is open now it's not looking at upon
only six but it's still a piece that can
hardly be or very rarely can be used
actively
and it's very often just yeah sitting on
the color of the pawn chain and is a
long-term liability Gillis is traded and
white has lost his important d3 bishop
so to be perfectly honest I think this
is just just just equal already there's
not much happening Group B 1 and B 5
yeah a typical way to combat the a4 b5
idea the so-called minority attack with
be five blankets just stopping any a4 b5
ambitions in its tracks this idea to
just play b5 may look a little bit
awkward because of the c6 pawn which is
a backward pawn but on the other hand
what black is doing he fixes lots of
pawns on dark squares and a knight
coming to c 4 will probably be very
well-placed as it detects day three Pawn
this setup would be five against the
minority attack is fairly popular and is
especially interesting when light
squared bishops are traded yeah in a
situation where let's say there's still
a bishop on e2 and the bishop on b7 this
is obviously less attractive as the dish
that b7 bishop is pretty bad but here
this is no problem at all yeah white
played a 4 rupee eight and now traded on
f6 this is a I think a wise decision the
bishop is quite often ending up as a
pretty useless piece as everything is
happening on the light squares a 6b 5d
6d 5 and the bishop sitting on d3 is
basically pointing into thin air so
trade it and a 5 it's also quite normal
you control will be six so that the
night is not jumping in in to see for
quickly Blackham is looking forward to
that idea and getting the night to see
for but now it takes quite a while yeah
you need to go to g6 which is really
long long way like this um where do you
go from there
now g6e 7 f 5 and so on it's a ton of
moose yeah and dumb no we continue this
a little bit improving yet white is
coming with this night all the way here
and now we captured with the beep horn
um the idea of this capture is that this
regrouping of the night will attack the
two points there are a six and c6 here
we go as promised the two pawns are
under fire but the thing is black covers
dead and has still no particular
problems with the double looks on the
ephod 'if is impossible to play really
they continued for a long while white
was trying something it's not like he
just sat down see he's trying to prepare
you for and very yeah it takes a while
but trying to prepare that always keep
in mind that whenever you fall comes
here does go there is huge pressure here
just taken and after some trades we
reach a completely completely equal
position I actually was a bit too quick
here there was one moment here I was too
quick there was one moment where Maxime
were Sheila graph could have taken the
porn on 86 it is however nothing much
because Luke a7 sends the night bag back
immediately and black gets the pawn back
I just wanted to show the silver line so
on there was never anything just hanging
on a six yeah a very very solid draw
which certainly yeah it doesn't get any
one very enthusiastic but those games as
mentioned they do happen
um especially in a situation where we go
back there where a new moves are almost
new move this plate it's kind of
surprising maybe sure f5 looks like very
normal as developing this piece um when
a new move of an uncommon move this
plate that sometimes the choice is a
solid one a simple one that is not yeah
testing the idea that much and quite
often leading to somewhat somewhat
boring games like here with e3 and
Bishop d3 okay now to the final and most
interesting game of this round the world
champion magnus carlsen playing white
can shockey on mummy dr off the top
layer of azerbaijan let's get going yeah
God's love very popular opening nowadays
and cars and goes for this so-called
slow sloth with 93 and III yeah not a
continuation that looks particularly
ambitious but nowadays is one of whites
main choices the thing is that Knight c3
which is the gap probably still the main
line the transitional mainland at least
after d takes you four is currently
giving white pretty much nothing very
little um the alternatives to e3 here
are pretty we are pretty pretty rare
they're not there's not much there's
Quincy to queen bee three as we've seen
in kiwanis I'm sorry Geary's game with
queen bee three that is ok but nothing
great so widest ride around here bit and
III is one of them moves that are
possible them yeah III first thing you
say okay isn't this a bit of passive it
blocks the bishop this Bishop once you
want yes it does but it is not
particularly problematic if black tries
to let's say make it better you can play
the bishop outside of the pawn chain
which is that the main
move then what has this idea where the
night is starting a change of this
Bishop white will very often get the
bishop Pam in some shape or form it um
it depends a little bit but very often
wyd will let's a take on g6 and some
some way this is a bit accommodating
bishop g6 but I can also start with
Bishop before or something else but this
kind of thing white is getting the
bishop here in a relatively close
position and long-term very long term
white might get any form and try to make
use of his two bishops um this is why
its main idea with this slow Slav that
the bishop 105 is mostly something
something that resembles a target and
can be traded off to gain the bishop Pam
blackheads alternatives though and now
the software is actually getting back to
where I wanted like has alternatives
mamma jamma plays g6 normal-looking move
but not not very popular it is a bit
passive to be honest and quite um
surprising that he plays it um
alternatives to Bishop f5 are besides
g6e 6 a-6 all those moves are normal and
playable well g6 let's see what is this
actually this is the so called selective
variation of the Slav the comes from car
collector the Austrian player was very
close to becoming world champion when he
drew a match against last come on yeah
schlechter invented this setup which is
basically some kind of hybrid between
the gruene fat and the Slav yeah we have
a night on partner d5 like the gruene
felt but black has not managed to play
c5 in one go but played c6 to just
support the center a little bit um here
in this particular position black has
some alternatives Bishop g4 for example
I can take on c4 I can play 6v6 is also
that's a very that's a flexible like
wants to
fianchetto yeah and maybe set up
something like bishop to be seven-night
bd7 e6 Queenie 7 ultimately c5 this kind
of thing hmm if white is responding with
the slowish blood of himself he very
often um will get nowhere yeah let's say
that moved like be three or so this is
relatively tame there should be seven
there should be two nite bg7 yeah here
black cam has no particular problem now
ye 627 being a possible way to continue
white after b6 should do something more
drastic let's aim and cars and goes for
a phone yeah I think this is a good idea
try to do something with the queenside
on structure and not allowed like to
fully develop and then yeah just we'd be
flexible and see what white is doing a 4
a 5 is something that black has to
attend to anti went a 5 just blocking
and this is actually some known position
after C takes d5 now in the game are not
run um from two thousand ten nine txt
file force plate however after this
efore not before you should be three of
play in the game white the then world
champion vision odd was certainly a
little bit better yeah white has a green
felt like center which is at the moment
not really under any serious pressure
and black has some weaknesses on the
queenside white is definitely a little
bit better him when cd5 is not a move
that looks particularly bad so why not
take with the pawn causal played be
three however the next move um I don't
agree with and well the computer
supports this view I immediately was
quite suspicious but when you check this
with the engine it becomes clear that
this next move wasn't a great idea
Mahmoud yarrow should just probably
continue
the developing move like a bishop here
96 something something normal why it
will always be a little bit better
because of the fact that the bishop on
e2 is somehow related to the queenside
play I know that is symmetrical the
Queen side is symmetrical but what white
has he has a bishop money to that can be
used on b5 on anyway on the queenside
well the g7 bishop is biting on this
default on that is safely protected this
is often a problem of this variation the
bishop on g7 is not really participating
much in the game in the gruene felt when
c5 is played often the deep bone is
removed even by a pawn sacrifice and the
bishop is coming to life he is just
looking at a protected pawn and white s
mentioned has his bishop that can be
used yeah what did mama dro play plate
nighty for this is losing a little bit
of time moving this night again um and
what it does it it alters the pawn
structure in an unfavorable way to be
perfectly honest I am a bit puzzled why
he went for that because the other or
the normal position let's say the
symmetrical wasn't very attractive but
having to get that the night has an
excellent square now on c4 the bishop
for white will activate on a 3 while
blacks bishop is still biting on this
this pawn and if black puts this Bishop
on b7 again it looks at a pawn so to me
it looks immediately very unattractive
this this black position and never be
puzzled why he went for it um maybe
maybe hard to tell but maybe he was
planning to go if I'm in this position
trying to yeah to really play it in a
violent way I break open the position if
white takes Bishop takes this might be
even be feasible but why it has a much
stronger continuation after this 'if
I've move he can go
this is a very strong move the idea is
that after Queen d5 Bishop a three ruki
g8 white can take on the form with a
little technical trick using also the
fact that white is much better developed
and now the White Queen has no move as
da does hanging yeah a very
uncomfortable position where white has
excellently activated pieces for example
of bishop a6 let's say 2555 and what
what are we going to do maybe rookie one
other back rank as a problem what has a
huge advantage him d 5 is so making
things even much much worse so he went
for Bishop d7 protecting the e4 pawn but
here we pretty quickly see that Bishop a
3 now you five is prevented f5 rook see
one yeah all this is very normal white
has just a far better position this is a
much weaker calm than b3 and both blacks
bishop are ya are passive 97 and d5 yeah
very nice active continuation white is
opening up the diagonal of the bishop on
just haven't but he trades in for
something else this push to d6 only
leaves black with a very unpleasant
choice he can take on d6 after which 96
will probably win this game in very
short order the night on d6 is super
strong and something like this for
example
yeah like will not not survive this
crossfire of pieces and you can either
allow the night to d6 or play Essex this
is what mamedyarov did he allowed this
very strong poem there on d6 ya know
Carlton goes from opening of the
position played in a very very
straightforward way yeah p 4 and a 5 we
want to open up to ultimately try to
support the B porn for promotion and
takes there was no big alternative
Queenie eight and now Queen a for ya
here White had a had a choice the other
move that looked rather promising was
Knight b6 but I'm not totally sure if it
if it does win this move is coming a
little bit later under somewhat similar
circumstances something like let's say
it takes and trades it's definitely
looking a very threatening but i'm not
i'm not totally sure quincy seven Queens
afire if white is really winning the
game probably probably yes but I
couldn't really um analyze it to a
forcing forcing win the computer gives
white like plus 11 point like 0.9 plus 1
something like that it it's not entirely
clear why does win by force the game
continuation Queen a force also very
very logical we use the Queen to try and
to enter on the queenside Bishop c6
queen before rupee aid and now Knight b6
yeah it's as mentioned a similar
situation here black only had one move
available he had to take on b6 after 96
Bishop be 627 let's say white is better
yeah this pawn on d6 is so a very very
nice asset but I'm not really able to
say if it is a total win or just very
good for white
yeah look the one for example on
doubling on the C file why this much
better but it's not completely Kiev it
should win and the computer is giving
like 0.8 0.7 you don't see you don't see
a clear evaluation why this much better
but it's not a clear winner in the game
whatever is a clear win mamedyarov place
95 that looks more active but it has a
big problem after Quincy five which was
played by Colin white has a substantial
threat in Bishop to c3 and this really
totally disturbs blacks coordination
hanging bishop and the diagonal he went
Bishop 28 and Queens Bishop c3 yeah and
now the problem is what is it that black
should do in this position he went night
back yeah there's no big alternative
down 97 jack takes takes chat and the
check that's the big problem now this he
file is open and rook c7 will be killin
ya after Queen e5 check mamedyarov
resigned the game so we have a win in
this round after ya form not very
eventful drawers there is a wind the
world champion has won his game against
the one of the local players against
mamedyarov um yeah this game is if you
ask me basically decided in here in this
particular moment let's say here when 94
was played this just yeah gets black
into huge trouble yeah I mean it's very
hard to imagine how black should
equalize from here he's just were so in
an inner structure would send something
that's not going away and he got under
that much pressure that he couldn't
defend ultimately maybe it was possible
with night XP six but after 95 Quincy
five intending the bishops III move
there is no defense yeah let's say if
black is doing something else yeah he
went for this if he plays let's say
another move night
to f7 what happens white cheeks what
happens if black plays the waiting let's
say age six yeah there is bishops III
there's d7d seven is also move that's
not not so easy to to parry 97 Queen c6
Bishop takes bishop c3 and West is not
going now sorry trickier if it goes to
the three checks and takes takes takes
check check there's tons of technical
problems in blacks position so it was
already not tenable after avoiding night
takes b6 on with 24 and in this
situation after Knight b6 here black
could have played a little bit oh yeah
could have been little is wrong he could
have continued the fight and when some
chance is to hold it but as he plated it
was it wasn't lost yeah I hope you
enjoyed this coverage of round two it
wasn't too eventful but still had some
interesting points especially the handle
game they over the world champion thanks
for watching I'll be back tomorrow and
tomorrow I'll leave you be a live
broadcasting on the ICC if you are icc
member you can listen to Grand Master
teamwork RAF and me commentating on the
third round of the event I'll also do a
game of the day or this recap video in
the evening european time as I did for
this round thanks for watching and yeah
talk soon or talk again tomorrow thanks